[Applaus]
[Musik]
habt ihr schon mal was von Guyana gehört
falls nicht dann merkt euch diesen Namen
gut denn Guyana könnte zukünftig zum
reichsten Land
Lateinamerikas avozieren der kleine
Start an der Atlantikküste Südamerikas
verspricht großes Potenzial und warum
nun das erklären wir euch in unserem
heutigen Video aber eines sei schon mal
verraten wenn man Öl ins Feuer gießt
dann lodern eben die Flammen es wird
also noch ziemlich heiß werden aber
eines nach dem anderen bestimmt hören
viele von euch heute zum ersten Mal von
Guyana es gehört zu den kleinsten als
auch den am wenigsten bekannten Ländern
auf dem amerikanischen Kontinent und
obwohl es geografisch zu Südamerika
gehört hat es starke kolonial und
sprachliche Bindungen zur
englischsprachigen Karibik tatsächlich
handelt es sich bei Guyana um das
einzige englischsprachige Land in ganz
Südamerika ähnliche wette auch das
wussten nur die wenigsten von Euch ein
weiteres Kennzeichen des Landes ist die
Armut hier sind die Menschen so arm dass
deswegen mehr Guyana im Ausland leben
als in Guyana selbst viele Jena die
zurückbleiben überleben nur indem sie
genau das tun was auch ihre Großeltern
schon Taten Reis anbauen holzschlagen
oder Goldschürfen und die so ziemlich
einzige Statistik bei der Guyana in den
oberen Rängen landet betrifft die
müttersterblichkeitsrate im ganzen
Südamerika wird es dabei nur von Haiti
übertroffen und was die restlichen Daten
anbelangt nun ja gelinde gesagt sind sie
genauso fatal vor fünf Jahren lag das
Pro kopfeinkommen bei 8.100 Dollar pro
Jahr weniger als die Hälfte des
südamerikanischen Durchschnitts die
Arbeitslosenquote bliebt sich auf 15%
verglichen mit den 7% in der gesamten
Region und die Lebenserwartung bedrucken
mickrige 69 Jahre während der
Durchschnittswert in die Nachbarländern
bei 75 Jahren lag aber aufgepasst denn
jetzt deutet alles darauf denn dass sich
das Schicksal Guyana komplett verändern
könnte
Guyana ist auf dem Weg ein weltweit
führender Ölproduzent zu werden 2015
entdeckte ein Konsortium unter der
Leitung des US-Giganten Exo mobile Erdöl
unter den Gewässern Guyanas
[Musik]
und seitdem haben Ex von Mobile und
seine Partner das ebenfalls
US-amerikanische Unternehmen Hess
Corporation und die staatliche China
national offshore Olga Operation März 30
bei heizungsvolle vorkommen entdeckt
schätzungen zufolge sind es inzwischen
mindestens 11 Millionen Barrel Öl auf
die sie bisher gestoßen sind und die
Suche geht weiter es wird prognostiziert
das Guyana bis zum Jahr 2030 eine
Million Barrel pro Tag fördern wird
besonders optimistische Zahlen rechnen
zwischen den Jahren 2030 und 35 sogar
mit 1,5 Millionen damit wäre Guyana
nichts geringeres als der größte
Ölproduzent der Welt gerechnet auf den
pro-kopf-anteil sozusagen das neue
Q-Wert wie viele bereits zu sagen
pflegen meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer die Petro Dollars könnten
eines der ärmsten Länder Südamerikas
schnell in eines der reichsten
verwandeln eine Erfolgsgeschichte aller
vom Tellerwäscher zum Millionär aber
aufgepasst in Öl wird die ist besonders
bei schwachen Regierungen häufig der
Fall ist zum potenziellen Ausgangspunkt
für Korruption und die traditionelle
Stabilität ist in Guyana alles andere
als gewährt die Frage lautet also werden
die petrolas die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung Guyanas ankurbeln und
tausend von Menschen aus der Armut
befreien oder werden sie eher ein hohem
Bogen aus dem Fenster geworfen oder gar
gestohlen so wie wir es schon oft
gesehen haben heute werden wir all
diesen spannenden Fragen nachgehen und
zwar gleich nach einem kurzen
Werbehinweis von unserem treuen Sponsor
surfshark denn surfshark VPN ist ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches zum Beispiel keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein Virtual Private networkurs VPN
einen nicht vor allem Gefahrenschutz
nebennetz lauern man muss nach wie vor
Umsicht walten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen
messen nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören mit
Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures
könnt ihr zum Beispiel eure Anonymität
im Netz erhöhen z.B mit den integrierten
clean Web das alle Cookies und Pop-ups
blockt weiterer Vorteil eines VPN ist
dass ihr so tun könnt als wäre dir einem
anderen so könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch
Websites und Internetdienste zugreifen
die in dem Land in dem wir gerade seid
nicht verfügbar wären ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt Zensur und
geoblocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
andere Streamingdienste die ihre Inhalte
nur in den USA Anbieten von Europa
ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles damit nur einem Server
Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VPN registrieren ob Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt ihr von surfshark auch
noch einen Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und
obendrein die ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nicht viel los besorgt euch
Surfer und greift damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter die
Arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt
mit Hilfe des PayPal Spenden links den
ich euch ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hättet
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
jetzt ab nach Südamerika wo wir wie so
oft mit einem schnellen Blick auf die
Geschichte beginnen
ein gespaltenes Land
[Musik]
im frühen 17 Jahrhundert von den
Holländern kolonisiert wurde Guyana 1815
zur britischen Kolonie noch lange vor
dem Öl war es damals der Zucker der
dieses Gebiet im Norden Südamerikas
grundlegend veränderte der Bedarf an
Arbeitskräften für die
Zuckerrohrplantagen veranlaster die
Kolonisten tausende afrikanisches
Sklaven nach Guyana zu bringen heute
machen ihre Nachkommen die sogenannten
afro-royana und ein Drittel der
Gesamtbevölkerung des Landes aus aber
wie ihr natürlich wisst kam
glücklicherweise die Zeit in der der
Besitz von Sklaven verboten wurde im
Jahr 1838 setze das britische Empire das
sklaverein allen seine
Herrschaftsgebieten ein endgültiges Ende
und von woher glaubt ihr holte man sich
die vielen billigen Arbeitskräfte die
deshalb dringend benötigt wurden ja
genau von Indien dem wahren kronjuwildes
Empire
Kulis lautete der Spitzname verträger
und Geringqualifizierte Arbeiter die
hauptsächlich aus Indien und anderen
asiatischen Ländern kamen die indischen
Kulis wurden für Verträge von mindestens
8 Jahren angeworben und erhielt im
Gegenzug Mittel für Transport und einen
Lohn nach dieser Zeit konnte der
Arbeiter wieder nach Hause zurückkehren
oder sich einen anderen Job suchen
zwischen 1838 und 1917 wanderten
aufgrund dessen Indien erlassenen
Verbotes über die Anwerbung von Kulis
mehr als 200.000 in der nach Guyana aus
[Musik]
und die Auswirkungen zeigen sich bis
heute von den knapp 800.000 Einwohnern
Guyanas stammen mehr als 40% von diesen
Kulis ab deren Arbeit war es auch die
den zuckerraupe Plantagen zu jahrzehnter
langer Prosperität verhalf sie werden
heute noch als Indo Guyana bezeichnen
und arbeiten mehrheitlich noch in der
Landwirtschaft bilden also sozusagen den
Großteil der Landbevölkerung des Landes
außerdem sind sie derzeit die größte
ethnische Gruppe in Guyana Mitte des 20
Jahrhunderts trat dann jagen auf die
Bildfläche er war als der die Bewegung
für die Unabhängigkeit Guyanas anführte
kleiner fun fact am Rande nach ihm ist
übrigens auch der wichtigste Flughafen
in der Region benannt gegen die
damaligen Unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen
leisteten die Briten eigentlich keinen
großen Widerstand aber jagen der als
Vertreter des modernen Trojaners Geld
hatte etwas an sich das Washington zu
einer Zeit als er Kalte Krieg auf dem
Höhepunkt war gar nicht in den Kram
passte er war Kommunist
aus diesem Grund boten die Vereinigten
Staaten Forbes burningham dem Anführer
der afro-royana ihre Unterstützung an
was ich als fataler Fehler entpuppte
dieser Anführer führte schwere
Rassenkonflikte zwischen den
afroguyanern und den Indo guyanern bei
den Unruhen 1964 gab es 170 Tote und
viele zerstörte Häuser infolgedessen zog
die Bevölkerung in Gebiete in denen ihre
eigene in der Mehrheit war was so eine
tiefen sozialen Spaltung führte trotzdem
verhaltet die britische Kolonialmacht
Burnham an die Macht zu kommen 1966 als
Guyana unabhängig wurde schaffte er erst
an die Führungsspitze des Landes
[Musik]
anschließend beherrschten drei
Jahrzehnte lang die Afro Guyana das Land
aber es liegt nicht so wie der besten
ist geplant hatte Trojaner wurde
schließlich auch zu einer Art Mini
Cooper Burnham machte sich daran die
wichtigsten Industrie des Landes zu
verstaatlichen der Staat kontrollierte
ganze 75% der Produktion während Wahlen
immer wieder von der Regierung
manipuliert worden und am Ende waren
selbst Grundnahrungsmittel wie Käse und
Weizenmehl nirgendwo mehr zu bekommen
die vielen Beschränkungen und Maßnahmen
die unter dem Sozialismus von Präsident
burnheim eingeführt wurden führten im
Guyana zu untragbaren Schulden und einem
sehr langsamen Wachstum schrecklich
verarmt und am Boden zerstört musste
Guyana den IDF um Hilfe bitten und
begann erst nach Burgenlands Tod sich
langsam zu einer Demokratie zu wandeln
1992 wurden die ersten freien Wahlen
abgehalten und der Sieger war ein
altbekanntes Gesicht na hat jemand eine
Idee genau shady Jaden
seitdem ist die Politik Guyanas
rassistisch gespalten in die Partei der
indoguyana und die Partei der Afro
Guyana und eines wissen wir ja alle wenn
sich die Wähler mehr um die Identität
als um die Leistung Ihrer Politiker
kümmern führt das nie zu etwas Gutem
Gegenteil zunächst einmal verschärft
sich der rassenkonflikt sogar in der
Hauptstadt und den anderen Städten in
denen die afroguyana in der
überzahlbaren wollte man nicht so recht
glauben dass der landbevölkerungsanteil
der endogurianer tatsächlich höher ist
und da sie bevölkerungstechnisch die
Mehrheit bildeten bei der Sieg von Chedi
jaygiens Anhängern natürlich für zwei
Jahrzehnte garantiert so kam es aber bei
jeder Wahl zu schweren Unruhen und zu
allem Übel verbesserten sich auch die
allgemeine Lebensbedingungen nicht
wirklich
[Musik]
23 Jahre lang plagten wirtschaftliche
Stagnation Korruption Vetternwirtschaft
das Wachstum des organisierten
Verbrechens und des Drogenhandels die
endokrianische Regierung war g also
zunächst eine kommunistische Diktatur
gewesen verwandelte es sich schließlich
in einem miserable Sozialdemokratie und
wieder einmal gab es Schlagzeilen für
die niemand verantwortlich sein wollte
Guyana das sind Geisteskrankheiten
Hexerei und die höchste Selbstmordrate
der Welt ihr seht schon es sah nicht
gerade rosig für Guyana aus aber
aufgepasst das Jahr 2015 brachte einen
großen Wandel mit sich und wurde so eine
Art Schlüsseljahr für Guyana und das aus
genau zwei Gründen erstens weil ein
politischer Wandel stattfand die Afro
Guyana schafften es mit einem knappen
Sieg von nur 4.500 stimmen die Macht
wieder für sich zu gewinnen der
Schlüssel zum Erfolg war jedoch ihre
Koalition mit einer multirassischen
Partei die jenes denken überwinden
wollte dass die Guyana mehr als ein
halbes Jahrhundert lange Spalten hatte
zweitens war 2015 das Jahr in dem man
zum ersten Mal unter seinem Gewässern
auf das schwarze Gold stieß die erste
erdöl-entdeckung der viele weitere
folgten und Guyana endgültig zu einen
neuen Stellen am globalen
ölindustrie-himmel machten
tatsächlich ist Guyana seit 2015
weltweit führend bei den
offshore-entdeckungen so machten diese
32% des gesamten konventionellen Erdöls
aus das sind diesen Zeitraum weltweit
gefunden wurde und wenn ein Land starke
Institutionen hat kann Öl natürlich sein
Wachstum fördern wie man am Beispiel
Norwegens oder auch Kanadas sehen kann
für Länder mit schwachen Institutionen
wie Guyana kann es allerdings auch den
Ruin bedeuten tatsächlich müssen sich
die guyaner nicht weit umsehen um einen
bestimmten Fall beobachten zu können der
ein Negativbeispiel para excellence
darstellt und an dem man sieht was
passiert wenn die Dinge gehörig in die
Hose gehen westlich von Guyana liegt
nämlich Venezuela hier finanziert das Öl
eine korruptes Regime dass die Menschen
immer stärker verarmeln lässt dieses
Thema jedoch werden wir in aller
Ausführlichkeit auf unserem
schwesterkanal visual economic
analysieren wartet mal ihr habt noch
nichts von Visual economic gehört und
ihn noch nicht abonniert dann müsst ihr
dies unbedingt nachholen den Link dazu
findet ihr hinter dem i und in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video denn
visual ist wirklich die perfekte
Ergänzung zu visualpolitik aber kommen
wir zurück nach Guyana die Frage die
sich jetzt immer noch stellt ist welchem
Schicksal ist Guyana denn nun
schlussendlich geweiht nun hört gut zu
[Musik]
der Fluch der Rohstoffe
die neue Regierung unter David Granger
war dafür zuständig die Bedingungen für
die Gewinnbeteiligung Guyanas mit dem
erdölkonservation Unterführung von Exxon
mobile auszuhandeln und fast unmittelbar
darauf brach der Streit aus die
Nichtregierungsorganisation global
business beschuldigte die Regierung
Rangers einen schlechten Deal mit den
Konsortium abgeschlossen zu haben dass
mehrere Bohrlöcher im starbrockblock
ausbohren sollte wie euch vorstellen
könnt war es dieselbe alte Geschichte
die bösen yankee-öl-firmen nehmen den
armen Menschen in Guyana ihren ganzen
Reichtum Weg laut dieser NGO könnte
Guyana bei den Verhandlungen mit extra
mobile bis zu 55 Milliarden Dollar
anpotenziellen Einnahmen verloren haben
dieser Bericht hat der Regierung Granger
jedoch nur deswegen geschadet weil seine
Berechnungen nach Meinung mehrere
Analysten nicht ausreichend begründet
waren tatsächlich hatte Racer energy ein
weiteres Beratungsunternehmen
ausgerechnet dass der Anteil Guyanas
eigentlich viel höher ist nämlich 60%
und mit dieser Deal mit ähnlichen Deals
gleich ziehen würde aber schlechte Deals
und Ausbeutung ist nicht die einzige
Gefahr die dieser ressourcenflug mit
sich bringen kann habt ihr schon mal was
von der sogenannten holländischen
Krankheit gehört
das Phänomen der holländischen Krankheit
ist nach dem benannt was in den
Niederlanden über die Bühne ging nachdem
in den 70er Jahren Gasfelder entdeckt
wurden beim Verkauf von Rohstoffen auf
dem internationalen Märkten erhalten die
Förderunternehmen US-Dollars da diese
Unternehmen aber steuern und Löhne in
Landeswährung zahlen müssen müssen Sie
diese einkaufen was die Nachfrage nach
dieser erhöht und den Wert der Währung
steigen lässt eine plötzliche stärkere
Landeswährung kann sich auf andere
Unternehmen oder Branchen auswirken die
am Export beteiligt sind ihre
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wird dadurch
regelrecht zerschmettert außerdem kann
die Flut an neuem Geld dazu führen dass
die lokalen Preise stark ansteigen
ja und genau so etwas könnte passieren
sollte das ganze Ölgeld plötzlich in die
bereits angeschlagene Wirtschaft Guyanas
fließen über das Thema holländische
Krankheit haben wir bereits mehrere
Videos gedreht und ich werde sie euch in
der Beschreibung verlinken die Regierung
Granger ist sich dieser Gefahren bewusst
und hat deswegen einen staatsfon
angelegt den natural resources Frankfurt
bei der New Yorker Federal Reserve laut
gutianischen Gesetz fließen alle Öl
Einnahmen Guyanas zunächst in diesem
Fall und um diesen Reichtum für künftige
Generation zu bewahren hat der
Gesetzgeber Guyanas sehr starke
restriktive Bedingungen festgelegt so
werden die Mittel der Regierung bojanas
im Laufe der Zeit immer nur schrittweise
zur Verfügung gestellt aber das Problem
ist natürlich dass das Wissen um ein so
großes potenzielles Vermögen sehr
verlockend sein kann aber Granger
entschied sich schließlich dagegen sich
auf Kosten zukünftige ölaufnahmen zu
verschulden und damit die öffentlichen
Ausgaben zu erhöhen er weigerte sich
sogar die versprochenen Einnahmen zu
nutzen um alte noch offene Rechnungen zu
begleichen
[Musik]
und er traf dabei eine im Lande sehr
umstrittene Entscheidung er beschloss
die Verlust bringenden Zuckerplantagen
zu schließen und das staatliche
zuckerproduktionsunternehmen nicht zu
retten dies führte jedoch zu starken
Unruhen unter den endokrianern die ganze
7000 Arbeitsplätze verloren das ist viel
in einem Land mit 800.000 Einwohnern es
wurde ein Misstrauensantrag gegen Ranger
eingebracht und plötzlich geschah das
und erwartete ein einzelner Abgeordneter
der mit den Afro guyanern regierenden
Koalition wurde das Zünglein an der
Waage und er änderte sein Votum brachte
die Regierung zu Fall
nun ja manchmal hat eine Mannschaft das
Glück in der letzten Minute ein Tor zu
schießen oder kurz vor dem Abpfiff einen
drei Punkte Wurf zu erzielen aber in der
Politik wissen wir nur zu gut dass es so
etwas die Glück nicht gibt und schon gar
keine Zufälle denn die Tatsache dass
dieser eine Abgeordnete anschließend
nach Kanada geflohen ist sobald über den
Misstrauensantrag abgestimmt wurde lässt
vermuten dass doch etwas verdammt faul
an der ganzen Sache war und alle Zweifel
wurden anschließend verstreut als die
neue indoganische Regierung diesen
Abgeordneten eine Auszeichnung verliehen
daran dass Person soll Hochkommissar von
Guyana in Indien werden nun ja die
Regierung Ranger war auch alles andere
als perfekt tatsächlich dauerte es ganze
5 Monate bis er das Wahlergebnis von
2020 anerkannt hatte und die
Präsidentschaft an den endokrianer
erfahren Ali abgrat fakt ist also das
auch Granger dem Fluch der Ressourcen
nicht entkommen konnte und die Macht
verloren hat auch wenn der Flug in
diesem Fall nicht wie üblich eintrat
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall haben sich die Dinge
seither nicht grundlegend verändert die
Pläne für die Verwendung der Erlöse die
aus dem schwarzen Gold fließen sind mehr
oder weniger dieselben geblieben und
eher einem klassischen Märchen
entsprechend folgt nun die Gier der
Nachbarländer natürliche Reichtümer zu
finden Weg auch immer das Interesse der
Nachbarschaft und Guyana kennt das nur
allzu gut tatsächlich blockierte es
jahrzehntelang die Ölförderung in einem
Seegebiet das von surinar beansprucht
wird bis ein internationales
cheatsverfahren 2007 den größten Teil
des umstrittenen Gebiets Guyana zusprach
aber wartet ein Moment in diesen Tagen
sieht sich Guyana einer neuen Bedrohung
gegenüber der Schirmbar
war schon immer ein Territorium
Venezuelas und Venezuela hat eine
koloniale imperiale Enteignung ermitteln
das sind Schulden des alten
Kolonialismus des alten Imperialismus
ist alten uralten und bereits
untergegangenen britischen Empire und
dieses Gebiet gehört uns es gehört den
venezueladern und wir werden es zurücker
die Entdeckung von Erdöl hat die
Ansprüche wenn er zu elas auch das
sogenannte Guyana assekiba das Gebiet
westlich des Flusses wiederbelebt und
das entspricht nicht weniger als zwei
Drittel des heutigen pro Jahr das
Problem für Maduro den wenn es
solanischen Präsidenten ist das
Venezuela 1889 die Grenze so wie sie
derzeit verläuft akzeptierte was damals
durch ein Schiedsverfahren festgelegt
wurde seit dem 1960er Jahren stellte
Venezuela doch immer wieder Ansprüche
und versucht Guyana wieder in das eigene
Land einzugliedern
vorerst hat Guyana diesen Fall dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof in Den
hach vorgelegt und wird wahrscheinlich
den gleichen Erfolg wie gegen sturinam
erzielen ein Urteil wird bis 2023
erwartet dennoch gab es bereits mehrere
Grenze Zwischenfälle zwischen der
venezianischen Marine und Schiffen die
in guyanischen Gewässern schippern es
ist daher nicht überraschend dass Guyana
sowohl im US Giganten Ex und mobile als
auch dem chinesischen Staatskonzern gute
Konditionen angeboten hat um sie in
diesem Konflikt auf die eigene Seite zu
ziehen alles deutet darauf hin dass
Guyana dank des Erdöls das von diesen
Konsortium entdeckt worden ist in den
Genuss eines noch nie da gewesenen
Reichtums kommen wird es kann ja nicht
schaden sowohl die USA als auch China
als Freunde zu haben nicht wahr Guyana
kann also zum Schlaraffenland werden die
brennende Frage die sich jetzt jedoch
immer noch stellt lautet wie wird Guyana
diesen enormen Reichtum nutzen und über
wie viel Kohle reden wir hier eigentlich
genau dann lasst uns mal nachsehen
Südamerikas
die entdeckten Ölreserven sind so groß
dass die Guyana in den nächsten 20
Jahren rund 160 Milliarden Dollar
einbringen könnten schaut euch mal an
für ein Land in dem ersten 40 Prozent
der 800.000 Einwohner in bitterer Armut
von weniger als 5 Dollar 50 pro Tag
leben wird das eine riesige Veränderung
darstellen und wir reden hier nicht nur
vorne rosaroten Luftschlössern allein im
Jahr 2022 werden die staatlichen
Einnahmen aus der
kohlenwasserstoffindustrie über eine
Milliarde Dollar betragen das sind
bereits jetzt etwa 1.250 US-Dollar pro
Kopf und fast 90% der regulären
Einnahmen der Regierung in den
vorherigen Jahren Guyana wird in der
Lage sein seine Ziele zu verwirklichen
und zu einem modernen und wohlhabenden
Land zu werden ein Ziel ist es zum
Beispiel die Flüsse zu nutzen und ein
Wasserkraftwerk zu bauen dass die Nation
mit sauberer und stabiler Energie
versorgen könnte der ideale Standort
dafür ist seit 1976 bekannt und schon
seit 1997 hat die Regierung von Guyana
Pläne für den Bau des Kraftwerks
[Musik]
in all den Jahren gilt jedoch eines die
840 Millionen Dollar die der Bau des am
Meiler forstprojekts kostet oder jemand
der das Geld für die Erschließung
aufbringen kann und will aber jetzt wird
dieses Problem zumindest theoretisch
gesehen verschwinden Guyana wird in der
Lage sein das Projekt zu finanzieren
oder außerdem wird die neue aufblühende
und wachsende Wirtschaft des Landes eine
Nachfrage nach energieerzeugen die das
Projekt auch rentabel machen würde
seltsamerweise hat sich das chinesische
Unternehmen das den Zuschlag für das
Projekt erhalten hatte jedoch gerade
zurückgezogen damit verzögert sich die
Inbetriebnahme vorerst bis mindestens
2.27 das ist ein ziemlicher Rückschlag
für Guyana aber Präsident Ali behauptet
fest dass sie das Projekt nicht aufgeben
werden schaut euch an
Norwegens independent Review Comedy hat
bestätigt dass dieses Projekt gut für
Guyana ist gut für die Umwelt und mehr
Wohlstand bringt dieses Projekt wird
also in Angriff genommen gerade aus
diesen ganzen Gründen die Alida nennt
überrascht ist dass dieses Projekt nicht
sofort in Angriff genommen wird auch
wenn es über die staatliche
Elektrizitätsgesellschaft läuft
letztendlich wird alles eine Frage der
Haushaltsdisziplin sein sollte hier die
Regierung nicht versagen wird es wohl
nicht so schlimm kommen
denn auf jeden Fall befinden sich eine
227 km lange Gaspipeline zur Küste und
ein erdgas-kraftwerk in der Nähe von
Georgetown bereits im Bau dafür
zuständig ist Exon mobile dass die
Kosten von den Erlösen abziehen wird die
Guyana zu fließen wie immer wenn die
endurojaner regieren gibt es aber noch
ein anderes schwarzes Loch in dem Geld
versinkt
[Musik]
seit ihrem Amtsantritt im August 2020
hat die Regierung von ihre Waren Ali das
staatliche zuckerunternehmen das
Schwierigkeiten und überhaupt Gehälter
zu zahlen mit einer Reihe saftiger
Kapitalspritzen versorgt es gibt eine
Reihe von Initiativen die Verlust
bringende Fabriken wieder öffnen wollen
nur weil sie beschäftigungsnischen für
endoguyana darstellen allein in den
letzten zwei Jahren wurden öffentliche
Hilfen in Höhe von rund 30 Milliarden
royalischen Dollar gewährt was in das
tun als Subventionen von etwa 140
Millionen Dollar entsprechen
bei der zu erwartenden Geldflut sind das
natürlich nur Brotkrümel denn was fest
steht ist dass sich Guyana in den
nächsten Jahren stark verändern wird mit
neuen Straßen Hefen Schulen
Krankenhäusern und so weiter tatsächlich
ist Guyana zu der am schnellsten
wachsenden Wirtschaft der Welt amüsiert
wir sprechen von sagenhaften 44% im Jahr
2020 von 20% im Jahr 2021 und bis Ende
22 erwartet die Regierung ein Wachstum
von haltet euch fest 48 %. und selbst
wenn wir das Öl aus der Gleichung
herausnehmen erreicht das Wachstum fast
8%, die Dinge laufen besser als je zuvor
in jeglicher Hinsicht die Regierung
arbeitet mit Mount Sinai und der Hess
Corporation zusammen um das
Gesundheitswesen in Guyana zu verbessern
die hess Corporation einer der drei
Ölkonzerne Guyanas ist ein wichtiger
Sponsor für das New Yorker Mounty
Hospital eines der renommiertesten
Krankenhäuser der Welt und hat die
Organisation maßgeblich an der
Modernisierung des Gesundheitswesens in
Guyana beteiligt
eine weitere positive Nachricht die von
den genannten Ölkonzernen ausgeht ist
die förderliche und treibende Wirkung
die seine Tätigkeit auf die Industrie
Guyanas hat es ist wahr dass die
Industrie viel größer sein könnte denn
es gibt Bereiche welche die kleinen
lokalen Unternehmen nicht erreichen
können in dem Land mangelt es bisher an
der Schwerindustrie aber genau da ist
etwas im Busch aufgepasst
guyanische Zulieferer profitieren von
Exon mobiles 540 Millionen
dollar-ausgaben angesichts der
Gesamtausgaben von Axon mobile für
dieses Projekt erscheinen 540 Millionen
Dollar als keine beträchtliches Summe
aber im Vergleich zum
Bruttoinlandsprodukt pro Jahr nass im
Jahr 2021 da 6,5 Milliarden Dollar
betrug ist das gar nicht mal so schlecht
außerdem versetzt der Erfolg von Mobile
Ingo ja das Land in eine bessere
Position um mit zukünftigen Investoren
günstigere Bedingungen auszuhandeln fakt
ist nämlich niemand absolut gar niemand
zweifelt mehr am Potenzial der Ölfelder
Guyanas einen kleinen Haken gibt es aber
an der ganzen Sache noch die
Attraktivität des Landes für Investoren
verstärkt von seiner Fähigkeit abhängen
Rechtssicherheit zu bieten und das
erfordert politische Stabilität wenn das
gelingt sieht es sehr ruhig für Guyana
aus und es könnte sich zu einem
monaco-lateinamerikas wandeln aber jetzt
seid ihr an der Reihe welche Zukunft
sagt ihr Guyana voraus was sollte das
Land eurer Meinung nach mit dem Ölgeld
machen wie immer sind auf eure angeregte
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt hat was ja gibt
uns bitte einen like heißt mit euren
Freunden vergesst nicht das Abo
unbedingt mit Glöckchen um keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mir das hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen PayPal
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]